the fact that there's still this issue
around the gatekeepers
who really has the power and the
authority over black voice
and black storytelling is very telling
and i hope that the film becomes a part
of that conversation
hi i'm rodda blank the writer director
and lead actor of the 40 year old
version
and this is my fresh first well the 40
year old version
is about a playwright who's down on her
look
and who turns to her old passion of
hip-hop to establish your voice as an
artist
in my very early 20s when i started
writing
theater and that was mainly because i
was a frustrated actor who couldn't book
a job
my first feature was actually an
adaptation of a book
it was a job that i got fired off of
everyone gets fired
at least one time and i think it's an
opportunity to really
you know decide like if filmmaking is
for you if you can get fired off of a
screenwriting job
and still want to make film then maybe
you are a filmmaker after all
the black and white of it all the reason
getting those no's
around the black and white of it was so
important is because i
really got to find out how much the
black and white element meant to me
you know i'm not just shooting it for
novelty's sake
i am showing hip hop culture in a more
sophisticated
more vulnerable light and and black and
white
does that
one of the comments i got is like yo sis
your movie's black as [ __ ] and that
touched me in ways i wasn't expecting
because i do want to make a story that
feels authentic to the black experience
especially in new york
and then the other comment was from
robert townsend
if there's any film that 40 year old
version talks to it's hollywood shuffle
you know both films are about black
creators
um contending and engaging with
white gatekeepers around who gets to
tell an authentic black story
the year started off so great i i felt
so affirmed as a film
director and then when it happened i
kind of questioned like
with the level of you know is this
really important
like when people are literally losing
their lives and suffering because of
this pandemic but like many americans i
was watching tv
and i was escaping through story and i
kind of
got revitalized again like feeling like
what an honor it is to tell story
because it really can um you know
inspire
and pull people through some dark times
water gotta have water jeez
be open and let your your nerves
be your fuel you can make your film
at any time find some friends who are
just as
passionate as you are and make that
residue for marawi
karima
you